commune de schaerbeek au coeur de
bruxelles un quartier populaire où vit
une partie de la diaspora marocaine la
plus importante communauté étrangère de
la capitale belge saïd à 40 ans il est
né au maroc il est arrivé en belgique à
l'âge de 1 an aujourd'hui il est
travailleur social ce matin il a rendez
vous avec saïd un jeune belgo marocain
de 23 ans qu'il a connu tout petit on y
voit on les voit
en direction le siège de l'association
jeunesse bruxelloise le quartier général
des marocains du point ayad un vieil ami
de saïd travail aussi aux côtés de la
population précaire de schaerbeek depuis
30 ans
grand bond en arrière nous sommes en
1964 bruxelles et rabat signer un accord
régulant l'envoi de travailleurs
marocains en belgique vers des abattoirs
dont deux atteints toi je vais je
voulais un truc ici saïd et ayad ont
déniché pour nous une vieille brochure
distribuée à l'époque aux futurs
migrants un discours qui aujourd'hui les
fait bien marrer ouvriers soyez les
bienvenus
avez vous déjà pensé à travailler en
belgique avez-vous déjà pris la grande
décision nous les belges sommes heureux
de vous voir nous offrir votre main
d'oeuvre et votre intelligence
nous souhaitons que cette vie nouvelle
contribuer à votre bonheur eh bien ils
ont changé d'avis
alors bailliage du truc qui me font
sourire pour le moment c'est votre main
d'oeuvre
dans les halles intelligence entre ce
que c'est
cinquante ans plus tard les trois
générations de marocains se sentent mal
intégrés dans la société belge vraiment
un arbre qu'on arrache et déracinés pour
replanter ailleurs maintenant que les
racines ont prise qu'est ce qui se passe
on dit ah non alors attendez maintenant
il ya un problème au ils font ce qu'ils
veulent à moi je suis belge je suis ici
je reste ici
dans ce pays il y à plus de 350 mille
personnes d'origine marocaine et les
9/10 comme saïd ont la nationalité belge
le lendemain saïd rejoint farouk l'un
des responsables de l'association lutte
contre l'exclusion sociale de molenbeek
le quartier où se sont installés les
premiers immigrants marocains au milieu
des années 60 ici on est dans le
croissant sud ouest qui est vraiment le
croissant le plus
la région possède la plus pauvre et la
plus populaire des cons à travers cette
canal on est dans un autre monde même si
on est toujours dans la même ville c'est
une certitude
pour en savoir plus direction le marché
ici c'est un petit bout de marocains
sont calmes quelle est la particularité
du marché de molenbeek je manquerais
prochaine tout est vrai et pas cher la
gare bolbec à caroline faye est là on
sent bien les odeurs
tout ça me fait
ça me fait retourner au pays selon une
étude récente de la fondation du roi
baudouin 53% des belgo marocains vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté la crise
économique la discrimination à
l'embauché et la stigmatisation des
musulmans rendre l'intégration difficile
en 2009 le quartier a même été le
théâtre de graves émeutes
on arrive chez les jeunes a vraiment une
justification qui se reposent sur des
sur des sur des analyses sociologiques
du genre voilà nos parents ont été
expliquées musset les côtés nous n'avons
nous aucun avenir ici dans ces 2011
quand vous emmerde
pour se rendre chez mohamed le frère de
saïd nous traversons les cités hlm
version belge
quand mohamed est arrivé en belgique il
avait 12 ans que nous sommes en 1971 une
autre époque c'est pas nous qui sont
venues du pays qui qui ont foutu le
si c'est moi l'expression le bordel qui
ont qui entendait des gens et puis on se
sont ceux qui s'ennuient ici c'est la
société belge qui a fait de ces gens-là
ce qu'ils sont c'est vrai il ya une
minorité visible et [ __ ] le boxon
et d'ailleurs il est plus facile d'avoir
la presse dessus à ces minorités la
queue que les centaines de milliers
d'autres qui sont cools qui qui ont
envie simplement de vivre peinard
l'horreur lors leur vie semblait ranger
personne etc en belgique la communauté
marocaine souffre d'une mauvaise image
résultats saïd se bat pour faire évoluer
les mentalités
un combat quotidien retour à schaerbeek
saïd retrouve son ami youssef éducateur
spécialisé auprès des jeunes en
difficulté
ces jeunes si ici sont des jeunes qui
témoigne déjà d'une volonté de faire
quelque chose de plus constructif sinon
il serait pas ici le meilleur vecteur
d'intégration chez les jeunes le
football un autre moyen de transmettre
le respect de la règle les cham est né
ici et pour lui pas question de mettre
en avant ses origines marocaines
les plus belles surpoids qu'adopter le
marquer boys ont marqué par aucun
tournoi congolais toi on est tous bien
pourquoi aux bagages et un discours en
forme de victoire pour saïd qui luttent
contre toutes les formes de
discrimination
et pour cela il a notamment créé
l'association carpediem objectif
responsabiliser les jeunes en difficulté
en autofinançant un projet humanitaire
cette semaine à bruxelles se tient la
11e édition du festival du cinéma
méditerranéen
l'association y tient un stand c'est
l'occasion de récolter des fonds
nous y retrouvons le jeune saïd dans un
rôle de bénévole
saïd rêve de devenir comédien alors la
soirée du festival c'est non seulement
l'occasion d'y faire des rencontres mais
aussi de croire en son destin le moment
idéal pour son aîné de l'encourager à
tenter sa chance
résultat les cozillons veulent bien et a
fait une provocation bien
je crois
oceane28 locaux comme pour le métier de
faut pas hésiter pourquoi vendre vendre
comme du van den bruwaene la vente la
qualité qualité doivent
remplacer à pouvoir
affaires de mme était mal choisi
jet aviation en belgique il reste encore
beaucoup de travail pour parvenir à
l'égalité des chances d'autant que les
marocains sur l'avenir du pays
aujourd'hui un bruxellois sur trois est
musulman selon les prévisions
démographiques
ils seront un sur deux à l'horizon 2030
[Musique]